the jurogan experience but i mean again
the news business is so star for revenue
um
that they'll you know they'll bend to
anybody basically did you see that i
mean i know jimmy dore covered it but
quite a few other people have realized
it now the amount of money the that bill
gates has spent
on uh influencing media no i i i did
it's somewhere in the neighborhood of
300 million dollars geez he's donated to
these various media organizations
which for sure has some sort of an
impact on how they cover him right well
of course yeah and
look the once upon a time we were
i have said it many times we were
trained to know
uh that for instance think tanks right
like uh
who they who
was funding them because think tanks are
who get quoted uh in the new york times
in the washington post right so
they're generating research that goes to
journalists and and
like sort of surreptitiously that that
ends up becoming what's covered and so
that's how like the gates foundation for
instance will work its way into coverage
uh you know it'll sponsor research in an
area like education that's one of the
things i'm covering now
um and its research becomes you know
[Music]
it gets it gets into the news that way
but we were supposed to once have uh uh
you know our ears up
and be conscious of who was paying for
all this this research where was that
information coming from and you know
people don't really even think about it
now see if you can find that story jimmy
i'm looking right now i'm reading a
article about
someone uh
last year actually was looking into it
uh here i'll show you
journalism skates keepers is what it's
called um
columbia journalism jfu
is that uh was respected yeah i mean
look they've had their issues but
they're that's the top
media criticism
outlet right
okay so this is last year says i
recently examined nearly 20 000
charitable grants the gates foundation
made through the end of june and found
that more than 250 million going towards
journalism receipts included news
operations like the bbc nbc al jazeera
pro-publica national journal the
guardian univision medium the financial
times the atlantic the texas tribune
gannett washington monthly le monde le
mans is that i say it yeah le mans and
the center for investigative reporting
charitable organizations affiliated with
news outlets like bbc media action the
new york times neediest cases fund media
companies such as the participant whose
documentary waiting for superman
supports gates agenda on charter schools
journalistic organizations such as the
pulitzer center on crisis reporting the
national press foundation and the
international center for journalists and
a variety of other groups creating news
content or working on journalism such as
the leo burnett company an ad agency the
gates that gates commissioned to create
a new site to promote the success of aid
groups in some cases recipients say they
distributed part of the funding as
subgrants to other journalistic
organizations which makes it difficult
to see the full picture of gates funding
into the fourth estate
yeah and and as a reporter you may not
may or may not be aware of all the
different ways that money will get in
you know work its way into the business
but unconsciously it just sort of seeps
in like right
and that's how it works like you
nobody comes and tells you well don't
cover this
um well maybe they do now actually
or or
you know take this approach to covering
education you what ends up happening is
that you just kind of get a feel based
on the reaction of your editor to
whatever pitch
uh you're giving at the moment hey would
you you know would you be interested in
the story about
whether or not um you know this approach
to
uh standardized testing worked right
uh and if the editor says yeah that's
interesting maybe right then you know
just never to broach that again right
but if if it's with you know in the cert
in the right ideological
slant um they're going to be hot for it
right interesting yeah and that's how it
works that's how it works with
everything it works you know and with
foreign policy
uh
i mean when i worked in russia
um
if you send the story if you pitch the
story to an american editor about how
uh
the u.s base the u.s funded reform
effort was working and there was a
growing middle class in provincial
russia
that was prospering and people were now
taking vacations to ibiza and stuff like
that you could get anybody to buy that
story but if you came to them with a
story about how
actually
um you know the trend the transformation
of capitalism has been really slow
people have lost their health care
um there's an out explosion of violent
crime and an addiction and people are
more and more gravitating towards
right wing politics uh you know
in large part because of the the rapid
changes that they weren't ready for
um you could not get that story sold
right so what ended up happening when i
was in russia
is they kept sending back all these
these
positive reports about what was
happening this was before putin
um
and americans got this idea that things
on russia were going great you know uh
and the the company was really
prospering in fact
you know i was doing stories when i was
there about how
money didn't even exist in in the in the
villages like the only people who would
actually have cash in in most remote
russian villages would be pensioners
because they would get it um you know
once a month from the mail system
uh
i went to places where the people
actually bought and sold things with uh
moonshine like the russian equivalent of
moonshine because that was like a unit
of currency i think wow they were doing
subsistence farming i mean it was
completely [ __ ] like life in rural
russia but if you picked up the new york
times what you read is you know the
emerging middle class was doing great
you know people have people have vcrs
and in samara and stuff like that and
that's how it works like you you you get
a sense of what they want you give it to
them and you know over time you just
stop thinking about it uh but it's it's
not a healthy way to do it